whoa whoa no way no no oh what is going on there
citizens of the reject Nation Greg here joined
by someone I remember when I first met you it
was like that experience when you're so used to
seeing someone on like television all the time
because I'm a star because you're so freaking
famous I don't know when I met you I was like oh
she's like out of the box that I'm used to seeing
her in and uh he couldn't have been worse it was
just a horrible human being Roxy striers with us
today people everyone says that that I make the
most intimidating first impression and I'm just a
little softy I think it's because you're uh you're
honest you got like a edgy crude sense of humor
you're welcome and thank you anyway guys we're
gonna watch some scary ghosts Roxy picked this one
paranormal stuff right shocking paranormal videos
leave Skeptics baffled I'm the skeptic you're
the skeptic I believe this are you Ted Lazo uh I
believe I don't get the reference I haven't done
that's another bag we don't have to open today so
I'm not going to apologize for that I haven't seen
last we're about to film a movie reaction this
video is coming to you guys way after that movie
reaction is up on the channel but I was like no
we should probably shoot a short video together
first Roxy has partnered up with two other very
lovely human beings dorina and Steph you might
have seen on my brother's Channel a snagged
up Roxy first yeah so no not today javikaway
we're gonna watch this video let's see where our
hearts lie all right for our souls oh damnation
how you doing I'm calling and this
is slapped ham today we're looking
at some scary video clips that can't be explained
get ready like this
when a security guard watching the video feeds
from his post in Mexico reported for work he
probably wasn't expecting to see any paranormal
videos however on this particular day something
appeared on the closed circuit cameras that he
and his co-workers had a difficult time explaining
workers standing watch outside he was shocked
to notice a mysterious figure standing only
a few yards away from them in the footage the
figure is completely dark it appears to be made
entirely of Shadow its shape is clearly human
but compared to the guards we see in the video
it's significantly shorter is it when the guard
watching the camera they immediately reported
to the co-workers standing nearby they quickly
turned towards the spot to investigate the two
men walked right up to the figure and shine
their flashlights directly at it however they
can see nothing oh come on it's freaky the guard
watching the video is perplexed as the shadow
still appears on the monitor what the other two
guards continue searching even appearing to pass
through the shadow figure at some points
whoa but they never see or feel anything
Peter Pan throughout the entire
investigation The Apparition never moves
what is this terrifying shadow creature
and why is it only visible on the video
feed the guards who experienced
it firsthand have no explanation
come on that is messed up the demanding
counter to ghost the skirts having a blast
no you don't think that might be real
the thing is listen Light Shadows they're
literally calling it Shadow we're putting
the light on it and it goes away shadow
it's humanoid though it's so humanoid
the shape was strange the shape was
strange it's probably like a light pole or
something that mic is so close to your mouth
I usually have the exact opposite problems
and I'm like yeah I put that night closer
and you're like let's just shove this mic right
this is better that's much better this is more
of your style it's more is more of my cup of tea
right I think okay let's see what else is in the
store from this video Jesus Peter Pan yeah
well that's what it is it's a shout out I I
get the reference thank you you can get Ted
lasso yeah well that last was not as famous
Okinawa Air Force Base in Japan thought
they saw something unusual Japanese is
scary we won the video and watch it
again to be sure I'm kind of with you
after a second look they were certain
they had found something that would
stand out among other unexplained
paranormal videos on the internet
the footage which was uploaded to YouTube by Jose
Cruz focuses on an intersection just outside the
base it's unclear what time it was when the
video was recorded but the sky is Inky black
just behind a road sign in the bottom left corner
of the screen a dark shadow begins to slowly amass
at first it looks like any ordinary Shadow as
it grows darker it becomes that's messed up
suddenly one Shadow raises itself from
the ground and flies across the road
oh that was weird actually a moment before
returning to the center of the street wow as
the shadow crosses the road the street lights
allow the camera to pick up more detail about
the apparition's shape it's like a lost soul
it's rather amorphous the overall shape appears
to be that of a human how do you know it's lost
I mean it's running in the [__] circles right
now no explanation for the strange events
but it convinced that a ghost was to blame
it could just be a glitch I'm just gonna write
that off as a question it isn't unusual for small
children to be fascinated by mirrors babies and
toddlers often find it endlessly amusing that the
child being reflected back at them copies their
movements exactly that hasn't left for me him
in one of the internet's more disturbing
paranormal videos however the child in
question may have been correct in assuming
that the image being reflected back
Theory video was uploaded to Twitter by nasrala
nappi as the child's mother films him playing
with the mirror the little boy turns towards her
together no way in a shocking twist the reflection
in the mirror doesn't copy the action is that
instead the reflection Captain is looking forward
and no it's so demonic mirror turning a terrifying
shade of black that little boy looks like me when
I was little no that has that cannot be weird
that can't be real sickens the reflection
suddenly looks like it's being fast forwarded
as the child in the mirror rushes to catch up
to the movements of the real life little boy what
the hell is going on something's wrong with him
the child's father to take him from
the room clearly she wants to keep
her child as far away from the mirror as possible
oh what do you think's going on in this
video don't know that one bogged I'm
bugged come on I don't know what else
that could be but also if that's my kid
I'm putting him in a room and never floating in
the Attic son like come on that your kid I would
freak out yeah or if it could be a parent pulling
a very elaborate prank how and then being like
we're gonna say this job our child's possessed for
the rest of his life I don't know you understand
the way that videos work that's not how they work
that'd be kind of crazy if these are parents just
trying to like make a dollar author kid but who
wouldn't right you know you got to make money
you gotta monetize your children once this is
why I'm not ready to be a parent because this
is the path you would take it's 100 you either
make me money or I'm keeping you in the house
or you're costing me money not nice what I
just said is not nice that's no it's fine
it's fine I assanted you but you're a woman so
you're gonna get more crap I'm ready for it the
smile was weird like the little smirk not I'm not
talking about the mirror kid I'm talking about kid
kid the actual kid Cape kid yeah kid kid had a
weird smile me or kid had the weird eyes though
that just seems so digital I feel like they kind
of this would have been creepy enough without the
eyes yeah it's gotta be fake a hundred percent
they made this up it's a good effect though
even if it's fake it's a good effect I'm kind of
afraid to look in a mirror again what if that's
what's happening when I look away you wouldn't
know you'll get over that feeling in like five
seconds yeah you're right you're right I love the
mirror yeah look at me that was a good one though
that was a good one like boy really does look like
young me really yeah not like do them look at me
now and go that's like I I've seen photos of me
when I was is an elaborate prank and it is you
it's off just to finally get you to believe when
Rosalia Lombardo died of pneumonia in 1920 at only
two years old her father was heartbroken wanting
to preserve her innocent Beauty for eternity
he sought out Sicilian embalmer and taxidermist
Alfredo salafia nope his body was well preserved
and still looks remarkably lifelike making her
a popular tourist attraction at the Capuchin
catacombs holy God so many fans of the Macabre
visit the girl's tomb for a very different reason
in various paranormal videos showing time-lapse
photographs of the mummy's face tourists who
have visited the tomb point out that her eyelids
sometimes appeared to be closed at other times
they appear to be open giving tourists a clear
view of her perfectly preserved blue eyes no
way they believed that her spirit still
lingers with her Earthly remains oh man
staff at the Museum have a different Theory
they assert that the mummy's eyelids are
always open the light that comes into the
Tomb at different angles throughout the
day causes an optical illusion that makes
her eyes appear to be closed at certain
times so you hide the devil spider this
logical explanation paranormal tourists
still flock to the tomb for a chance
to see the allegedly possessed mummy
I kinda want that from me I think when I die can
you do that for me yeah Greg will make it happen
for I have evidence for oxy settings this video
because that's kind of a cool way to stay alive
forever and haunt everybody yeah we could do that
at the Santa Monica pier where we'll get it done
for you thanks appreciate you Mikey no problema
is a popular figure in Latin American folklore
yes according to the story this legendary
woman in white was abandoned by her husband
the scorned woman attempts to exact revenge on
him by Drowning their three children after her
dastardly act she's immediately stricken by grief
and takes her own life in search of her children
and any who hear her mournful cries are said
to be cursed with bad luck while the legend is
popular the weeping woman doesn't often appear
in paranormal videos yet many believe that La
Llorona is the star of this viral clip uploaded
to YouTube by now you know why specifically like
the video shot in Mexico City a spot of white
gradually materializes the center of a street
suddenly the spot transforms into a woman with
long dark hair wearing a white dress it was weird
just as she materializes a car speeding
down the street drives right through her
she never moves even after the car drives
off she remains standing in the same spot
huh if just seeing the Weeping Woman brings bad
luck this motorist who ran her over
might be in for some serious trouble
that one was weird it did look like it could be
lighting but also the shape and like I was dark
on top light on bottom that was weird so
the contrast the colors will make you more
of a Believer yeah also like don't kill
your kids because your husband's a jerk
the pause I just had it I just had to think
for a little bit to make sure I just I was
like well you know it depends on the situation it
I guess it doesn't depend on every situation more
scared being in this room than I am watching
these videos okay I'm not gonna kill your kids
don't worry yes all zero of them maybe you already
killed them they don't exist taking a weird time
cool zigzag all right I'm keeping
up Christmas this is a soccer game
actually Greg it's football it's football
probably where since we're going all over
the map here some football fans leave for their
favorite teams well done well done these videos
to be believed one fan may have extended
their devotion into the Afterlife as well
County Football Club Stadium in Nottingham
England it appears that a ghostly figure
attempted to get a better view of the game by
staking out a position on the Stadium's roof
right in a close-up video you can see the
faint figure of a person walking along the
sloped edge of the roof oh come on it's walking
like the goddamn Predator look at that cloud bro
Cloud's body remains exactly perpendicular
to the roof at all times even when walking
down a steep slope that is clearly a legs a
leg through the clouds the figure is almost
entirely transparent but its appearance on the
stadium roof has yet to be logically explained
maybe I'm just smarter than the rest of you all in
Mexico to some of the most common ghostly Legends
they often have tragic pack stories that make
their appearances even more frightening yes in
one of the creepiest paranormal videos shared
by YouTube channel the hidden underbelly 2.0 a
mysterious woman in a white dress gives a couple
of security guards a good reason to be frightened
one of the two security guards working at
Galleria slapas a shopping mall in Mexico
sets out to do his usual Rounds Around the Mall
late one evening I'm never going to Mexico but
it remains behind to keep an eye on the security
cameras the guard notices nothing unusual as he
does his rounds he returns to his post seems
concerned the partner asks if he saw a woman
in white in the mall and the guard replies that
he didn't see anyone when the guard watches the
security video it becomes apparent why his partner
was so frightened clear as day a woman in a white
dress appears in the footage walking right past
the patrolling guard clear as day uh the white
dress image is completely opaque unlike many
paranormal videos showing more transparent ghosts
now that's the guard and that's the I get it
but that was no explanation I don't think this
is clear as day security video the shopping
mall where she was spotted has been known for
Supernatural occurrences in the past others
have spotted ghostly children in the morning
it's so ritual sacrifices
you know you Skeptics rich like a you're
gonna argue technicalities see I see her
clear as night like clear as Fog she does look
like a person but you know maybe he was just
like busy he could have been texting he didn't
see her he walked right through her next door
and it does kind of look like when you're really
slow it down it tells me like he's kind of going
around her and she's moving her shoulder
he is she's moving and he was texting stop
texting and walking it's very dangerous
what a terrible security guard then he
ought to be fired for some wandering woman
in the mall who are you calling you Skeptics
I'm sorry to me and my people Jewish people yeah
no my people are more paranoid than anybody I know
is that racist for me to affirm that no okay
I said it first so you can confirm yeah offer
the Jews are paranoid it's about mine yeah I'll
control this at it and get myself in trouble all
right I think there's one more left here let's
see if they can get me home run when Michael
Flannery moved into his wife's family home he
was nervous about the stories the rest of the
family told they were certain that the house
contained some sort of ghostly presence people
would regularly see and hear things that they
expect but it's intentionally fake in the family
were terrified of the house even refusing to go
into sir come on I decided to set up a hidden
camera in hopes of solving the mystery stockbrot
wasn't expecting the video shot in his bedroom to
be so terrific dude the video clearly depicts
what appears to be a large black cloud flying
quickly into the room and towards the ceiling
behind the camera I don't know what that is
that is weird it flies out again a few
seconds later following the same path
oh man some viewers have written off the video
believing that the cloud is simply a shadow of
something passing over a light bulb however
flanderini's family is certain that the video
depicts their resident Phantom what is the
difference exactly oh that was your number
one come on slapped him slap him all right
maybe their number one wasn't strong well it
is weird the shadow that goes through but the
shape that they made it like yeah it's like a
kid's dinosaur which could be their resident Dino
resident I know Barney what are you doing here
that's a movie waiting to be made resident Dino
I love you I'm a resident I know you can't see oh
it was falling off a cliff somehow
you are gonna let me die I was willing to I could
I could have jump cut it to a rhyme but I chose
to let that play in real time you trusted me I
trusted you I have faith in the female Jewish race
thanks it's a very specific
category we're a strong group
I'm believing in it now thanks well
this is not going to convert anyone
it's Judaism to believe it in goats right right
and Judaism unfortunately we don't know we could
that might be the comments I didn't believe in
ghosts but I am going to become a Jew now yeah
yeah well listen it's a better life if you don't
believe in them because if you really do start to
believe in ghosts you're in trouble okay good I
thought you were talking about Jews at first then
you clarified with the ghost you need to really
get our dialogue in order here they are similar
all right guys we'll subscribe to the slap Tam
please I'm gonna follow for a long time also
please follow Roxy on our social media links in
the description box and of course uh the World
Girls Channel watch them go to Vegas and get
drunk and you should do a video in Mexico that
would be amazing that's where three is from oh
is she from there yeah she's from Mexico oh my
God she's so sweet what made you just say we
should do a video in Mexico the fact that we
just watched three videos three things that
took place in Mexico right but then all the
people were haunted like why do you want me
to go somewhere oh come on the thumbnail man
of them the clicks will happen if you do it
there all right I'm down all right catch Roxy
in Mexico never coming back alive that's how
you that's the character then you're a believer